what is happening reject nation it's
Greg Alba hair it's John Humphrey over
here we're gonna watch the trailer for
Mortal Kombat annihilation today
fountains
I can't wait obviously haven't seen
other people's videos on this right Oh
to know for the first ones to make that
joke hahaha
this comes out a week after Valentine's
Day and it looks like a horror movie
or something like that see what's going
on a dark fantasy whoa okay three
trailer
[Music]
arrival
[Music]
can you describe this for
was it cold
[Music]
did it communicate with you wow the
rehab did to me
you really have no idea what it was
[Music]
because we'll contact you at any point
that's our Isaac
[Music]
whatever has the context whoa
tell me why his wisdom
[Music]
oh dude as not Mortal Kombat
annihilation not all no Goro doesn't
cool right you know what yeah it has
like the tone and style of a rival a
little bit of like oats to do in there -
yeah and then just some you know kind of
beautiful fantasy elements just you know
yeah it kinda reminds me of the movies
like Russian movie that I saw like a
hour of before I saw a good trailer for
it and I saw like an hour of the movie
it's called stalker oh yeah Andrei
Tarkovsky lot of that one is a guy leads
two men through an area known as the
zone to find a room that grants wishes
there's like a sort of psychological
deprivation of the human beings that are
be going yeah yeah this seems to have
similarities to that for sure so you see
that seems like a hybrid mix of a lot of
different things yeah it definitely has
some familiar elements and stuff and and
for a trailer you know I'm sure that's
partly I guess intentional on its own
this looked super intriguing to me I
mean I love the look of the world and it
definitely intrigued me do you want to
go in and hello this journey and see
what on earth it is that they found
knowing this director I'm sure it'll be
something that'll actually be rewarding
in the end yeah yeah I think I was a
pretty big kinda has a little bit slight
reminiscent qualities of like a
Prometheus and alien covenant but I feel
like will actually get answers yeah it
may be more than just thriller cuz it
doesn't seem like it hones in on all
like the crazy thriller aspects to it it
seems like it'll take its time be very
moody and also have a lot of dread
throughout it with that fantasy element
that feels beautiful but haunting at the
same time
yeah and that's perhaps the most
enticing part of this trailer for me
because that was the most unique element
is like the the stuff that's kind of
beautiful and sort of floral and
rainbow-colored and there is like a
wonder and a magic to whatever this
realm is beyond the parts that looks
sinister and dangerous
yeah area and yeah I get that sense that
there will be some actions some
thrilling moments in this movie
I don't think that comparing to
Prometheus I feel like Prometheus and an
alien and stuff like that those who want
to do the action stuff and then
occasionally take a break to go my
philosophy yeah where is this one I feel
like the opposite would be true oh
absolutely absolutely and I feel like
because it's a trailer you know kind of
like how arrival was marketed yeah where
they try to make a rival look like like
an alien invasion movie yeah it's not
that you know similarities with the
female lead like a sense of loss or
husband being in danger at least I have
a rival it was set up I won't spoil it
if you haven't seen it no he's just
Oscar Isaac fans in the hospital and
that's why she goes on this mission so
she's safe and I feel like for this kind
of director like the dude you did ex
machina yeah like I don't want I can't
spend too much time thinking like this
is exactly how I know it'll go down yeah
yeah there's some clues that you could
probably guess yeah we've seen at least
a lot of the movies that he's written
and we know the kind of subject matter
he tends to gravitate well he's great I
like philosophical debate yeah he's good
at making science fiction right now
making a thoughtful sci-fi that is also
really cool see this is like Alex
Garland's with a few guys right now
working and I feel like allows you to
have your cake and eat it too the
world's he treads in are always gripping
and intriguing but you know there's also
some thrilling and some you know
elements that are easy to enjoy as well
especially for something that's based
off a novel I feel like he would know
how to capture the essence of a novel
pretty well yeah totally and I mean he's
only directed one movie I believe this
far which was ex machina but he has such
things like he's writing writing credits
yeah yeah he's gotten he's written tons
of movies and he's worked with a ton of
great directors but ex machina was such
an assured and such a strong directorial
debut and this looks equally you know
composed and gripping Natalie Portman's
got a pretzel tattoo so Alec performing
such a terrible actress though yeah
can't stand her name one good movie
she's done episode three mr. Magorium's
wonder Emporium I can't really think of
anything else she's been let's leave it
there that's not clarifying everything
let's just leave it there I'll see you
yeah and this looks like a great way to
get back in a regular
movie mode after Fifty Shades freed
comes out watch the taste of Christian
Grey out of your mouth yes some dark
fantasy sci-fi yeah and also you know
not to say that the guy ever falls short
of thrills - that's that's the really
cool thing about like him and denis
villeneuve there's similar there's
similarities to me in terms of their
writing in direction they care more
about character they care more about
what the movies really all about and
what the fence has to go you're doing to
the people
yeah but they also don't sacrifice
thrilling aspects because they know how
to make stuff really intense and I feel
like I feel like Alex Garland perhaps
even more so like there's always cool
stuff yeah and his stuff that you want -
well yeah you do like 20 days letter
Dredd sunshiney anyway guys thanks for
sending that our way annihilation
finally a remake of Mortal Kombat 2 that
I've been waiting for seems like they're
sticking true to the game yeah yeah you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bail Dench on Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram and go check
out our patreon become a patron eject
today join us posted over a hundred
things over there find out what some of
those are